foreign
[Music]
stance is a fundamental position from
Chinese martial arts this is a low to
the ground wide stance that can be used
as an isometric hold for training but as
application goes far beyond martial arts
it can be extremely useful for everyone
from gym goers to athletes to anybody
else who just wants to improve the way
they feel and the way they move that
said the precise benefits you get from
the horse dance is going to vary a
little bit depending on precisely how
you perform it what your goals are and
which technique you use you'll find
there's lots of different explanations
about how to perform the horse dance so
in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about the history of the
horse dance the different types of horse
stance how I like to perform the horse
dance and how you should perform the
horse dance
foreign
troduced into my training in the last
six months or so I'm still not very good
I can only do like two minutes at a time
or a little bit more than that but I'm
shaking all over the place and in just a
matter of months I've really started to
notice a difference it's easier for me
to get in and out of a deep squat I have
more mobility and flexibility for kicks
and for things like crosstalk squats and
I have less pain and more stability in
my lower back better engagement of the
core and the glutes I've been doing some
other corrective exercises for my lower
back and for my mobility in this area as
I've been discussing in recent videos so
I can't say it's entirely due to the
horse stance but it's definitely played
a big role in the past I've done Tai Chi
and karate both of those Incorporated
the horse stance as a key part of their
training but with subtle variations it's
obviously in the horse stance what
you're doing is you're standing with
your legs wide apart in a lower stance
like I said what this is doing is
opening up the hips fish strengthening
your abductors and stretching the
adductors if you're doing this in a very
active manner so you're not just
building flexibility in a passive way
You're Building strength and stability
in those ranges of motion which means
you can more easily get down into a deep
squat this is really important because
changing height and level is an
essential part of many athletic Pursuits
and a lot of us just don't have this
ability in fact this can be so good for
developing Mobility you can actually use
the horse stance by progressively
getting wider to build up to a middle
splits there's actually a great video on
this a very old video from Daniel
vadnell at Fitness FAQs highly recommend
checking that out
at the same time though by sitting in
this position and holding it there for
sometimes minutes at a time what you're
doing is you're developing strength and
strength endurance in that area this is
fantastic for strengthening the glute
strengthening the hamstrings
strengthening the quads even the core
and because you're sitting in this
stretched position and resting
essentially on your tendons it's
brilliant for strengthening and
developing the tendons as well what
you're doing here when you're training
your hip mobility it's not just about
hip abduction and being able to raise
your leg to the side it's also about
external rotation get down really deep
into a body weight as the grass Squat
and then as you stand up if you find
it's actually quite hard to drive up
from the bottom of the squat there that
might be because your external rotation
is lacking and this can be a limiting
factor in back squats as well weighted
squats with all these different benefits
it's important to decide what your focus
is with the horse dance and then to
choose the right horse dance for you
because like I said there's different
versions and if you watch a few videos
on YouTube about how to do a horse dance
you're going to find they'll tell you
something slightly different and this
isn't because you know one of them's
wrong it's because they're legitimately
different methods with different
outcomes so if you're go back to those
traditional Chinese kung fu Roots then
you have your Northern style and your
southern style so your Northern styles
of kung fu are generally much lower to
the ground using wide stances acrobatic
Flying Kicks these include Styles such
as praying mantis and Eagle Claw and
yeah they look pretty flamboyant and as
such they use a much deeper and wider
horse stance in training in general
again there are different sub Styles and
it all depends on the goals and what
you're using horse stance for then you
have your Southern stars of kung fu your
wing chuns Etc these are slightly more
upright with the feet turned slightly
outwards this places less emphasis on
Mobility but allows you to generate more
power by twisting other martial arts
have since also adopted the horse stance
in various different forms in karate and
whatever you karate we used to call it
kibadachi it was a wider stance with
outwards turned toes so yeah there's
lots of different versions of the horse
dance depending on what you want to
achieve and as we'll see you can modify
it however you like to get the benefits
that you want
so how high or low you use the horse
down it's going to depend on which style
you're imitating and what the benefits
you want on we'll talk about why you
might use a higher stance in a moment of
course it's also going to depend on your
mobility and your strength you might be
limited and only able to get into a
slightly higher stance but a great
starting point a lot of people use is
the five-step horse stance so start with
your feet together then turn your heels
out then turn your toes out and turn
your heels out then turn your toes out
and then sit down into it so we're gonna
count that sitting down as the last step
this is going to get you into a good
starting position and if it's a bit too
hard then of course you can go narrower
if it's a bit too easy then you can go
wider over time but if you aim to hold
this for about 30 seconds to begin with
train this about three times a week and
over time you'll find it gets easier and
you should be able to start adding 10
seconds on here and there either every
week or maybe every Fortnight and as you
do you're going to get to higher and
higher times alternatively if you're
more interested in building that
Mobility working up to a side split then
you can increase the width instead what
you want to do if you're working on
mobility and strength in particular is
to make sure that your thighs are
parallel to the ground so you don't want
to be like this obviously if you do like
this that's fine as well but you're not
going to be building the strength and
Mobility to the same degree and if
you're not sure if you're deep enough
what you can do is grab a stick light
across your hips here and if it rolls
off then you're not deep enough if it
stays upright then you're fine now one
of the things that can vary depending on
who's teaching the horse stance is
whether you want to face the toes
forwards or slightly outwards if you're
facing the toes directly forwards then
this is going to help you to engage the
glutes in particular and the quads if
you face them slightly outwards this is
going to further externally rotate the
femurs making it slightly more of a
Mobility challenge both of these things
are completely fine and you will get the
same benefits from each it's just one
will slightly favor one one will
slightly favor the other you might find
that if you're slightly Limited in
Mobility you struggle slightly to get
your toes pointing directly forwards and
so you have to keep them pointing
outwards by necessity
speaking of which it's also important to
consider your Footwear and I think that
for this then once again Barefoot
training is by far the best way to go if
you look at how Kung Fu practitioners
would train they train in pumps or plim
Souls I think it's really useful
training the horse stance as incidental
training that means sneaking it into
your lifestyle doing things like getting
to horse stance whilst you're doing your
teeth or washing your hands and if you
wear barefoot shoes then you're using
the same posture in the same foot
position during brushing your teeth and
doing those things as you are when you
practice it out and about so this is
another good reason to use barefoot
shoes and if you're wearing shoes with
heels on though it's going to tip you
slightly forwards and alter that center
of gravity it's also going to slightly
alter the position of your pelvis so
these subtle changes will negatively
impact on the way you perform the
movement that brings me to today's
sponsor
which is Vivo barefoot in my opinion
Vivo Barefoot make the very best
barefoot shoes for a whole host of
reasons because they're ethically
sourced because they fit really well
they're really comfortable they're
highly durable and they have a fantastic
range of different shoes whether you
want to do trail running whether you're
looking for something to wear to the gym
or whether you're looking for something
to wear Just Around Town one of my
favorite things about these shoes though
is that you literally can wear them
doing literally anything obviously your
foot is designed to go barefoot so once
you're adapted to it this is the perfect
Footwear for every occasion I find that
they do look nice enough smart enough to
wear to a nice event or so I don't feel
odd when I'm dropping my daughter off at
preschool but at the same time I can
then wear them straight into the gym
wear the flat heel is perfect for weight
lifting have that nice solid connection
with the ground and if I want to
practice calisthenics it's ideal or I
can wear them somewhere like this to go
trail running or to perform martial arts
as you guys know I've been wearing
barefoot shoes for years and for most of
that it's been Vivo Barefoot just
because they last so long they're so
comfortable I just really love these
shoes so if you want to give them a try
yourself then you can use the code to
buy an air 15 the link in the
description down below and you'll get 15
off your first order thanks again
massively to Vivo Barefoot for
sponsoring this video and now on with
the show I do not appreciate how many
bugs they're going to be here today
don't really smell that bad
foreign
[Music]
of contention is your pelvis should you
have a slight anterior pelvic tilt
posterior or should you keep it neutral
well most people tell you to keep your
pelvis neutral and your spine neutral
you want to make sure you're standing
straight upright you're not leaning or
bending over forwards it's easy to do
this whilst thinking you're straight so
it can be useful to do it against the
wall or to check in a mirror and to
really learn what that feels like so you
can make sure you're up straight when
you're doing it on your own but in terms
of the pelvis keeping it neutral can
help you to maintain that upright
neutral spine and to engage the core but
there are some that say that a slight
posterior tilt tucking your tailbone
underneath can actually help you to
better route yourself to the ground here
you're creating something similar to a
hollow body position on Jesse ncamp's
Channel which is a fantastic martial
arts Channel that I highly recommend
there's a video where it goes to train
at The Shaolin Temple Europe with sifu
shiheng Yi today I'm training with a
Shaolin Master
and he talks about maintaining a slight
round posture which is essentially a
hollow body by slightly tucking in the
tailbone and by protracting the shoulder
blades slightly this allows him to then
redirect energy pushed against his hands
back into the ground rather than
toppling over a slight alteration to his
posture that completely changes his
structure this to me is fascinating and
it's called rooting and by rooting
yourself to the ground you can just
generate so much more power because
obviously so much of our power comes
from that ground reaction force whether
sprinting by pushing off the ground or
throwing a punch if you're not stable on
the ground you can't generate power and
project it outwards as for the arms
there's a number of things you can do
with these generally the advice is to
keep them nice and relaxed you can do
this by holding them out in front of you
like this as though you are holding a
beach ball and you're supposed to keep
them nicely relaxed which means broken
elbows broken wrists no tension in the
shoulders and what you're doing here is
training yourself to be tense and strong
in the legs whilst being relaxed in the
upper body this kind of relaxation
allows you to create more efficiency if
you want to last longer in this position
and it does become a test of endurance
then if your whole upper body is
contracted intense as well you're going
to run out of energy much more quickly
you're going to get uncomfortable much
more quickly by keeping the upper body
relaxed you can thereby maintain that
stable position for longer this
translates to martial arts whether they
whole idea is to stay nice and relaxed
and light until that moment of impact so
something that I need to work on I'm not
very good at relaxing my body so yeah
it's a really fantastic option
a similar option is to practice flowing
arm movements like something from Tai
Chi if you've ever done something like
that same kind of principle applies here
or the complete opposite end of the
spectrum you can practice your punches
making this more of a full body exercise
or drawing your fists back to your sides
back to your hips in order to really
reinforce those movement patterns this
like dropping your hands by your side
also makes the movement a little bit
harder because when your hands are out
in front of you the actors are
counterbalance what I like to do is this
position I do that because it's what
Jackie Chan does
and the final piece of the puzzle is
what you're going to do with your mind
and this is actually a really important
Focus so recently made a video saying
how cold showers weren't all there
cracked up to be for developing
discipline I think if you really want to
develop discipline and get all these
benefits at the same time then the horse
dance is a fantastic option because as
you push through those higher times you
need to really push those pain barriers
and the way to do this actually is to
relax your body to breathe gently
through the nose in a rhythmic manner
this is going to reduce the sensation of
pain from the build up of metabolites in
the legs and the working muscles but the
more you relax the easier it is to get
through this and that's an important
lesson for life and again here we're
controlling our central nervous system
if you want to get better at doing tough
stuff then exercise like this is a
fantastic option some people use this as
a form of standing or moving meditation
to try and quiet the mind in that
position whilst they maintain it and
this is where you might want to stand up
a little bit higher because now the
focus isn't obviously on building
strength and ability to the same degree
but you still get those a little bit I
really like this option of meditating
because I'm a parent and when I try and
meditate sitting down I so often fall
asleep which is a real problem but
perhaps for me what I think is the most
useful thing to do do during a horse
stance is to focus on your structure on
your position because there's so much to
remember here you think about the
position of your pelvis and you think
about your center of gravity are your
legs even mine often aren't you might
even notice in some of these clips
because I've got some imbalances
particularly in my right ankle which I
badly break you need to focus on your
breathing and remaining calm you need to
engage your core you need to keep your
back nice and upright and by focusing on
these things you can build a stronger
structure a better foundation for all
movement this is what we mean when we
say internal work focusing internally to
really work on those aspects of
performance and technique That You Don't
See on the outside and that's what's
often really important
also if I'm being really honest a lot of
the time I just watch real junk on
YouTube
useful interesting guys let me know down
below do you do the horse dance and what
is your record time I bet you can easily
beat mine have you noticed any benefits
from training with it either way guys
thanks so much for watching this one and
I'll see you next time bye for now